well kurt zuma appeared here with his
brother joanne both involved in this
attack on the cat they appeared here at
thames magistrates court
arriving for the sentencing and it was
last week where they appeared and both
pled guilty kurt pleaded guilty to two
counts of causing unnecessary suffering
to a protected animal and joanne pleaded
guilty to one count of aiding and
abetting
his brother now their sentencing today
lasted around 20 minutes they sat in the
dock together and kurt zuma was handed a
12-month community order that's going to
involve 180 hours of unpaid work his
brother joanne was handed a 12-month
community order also with 140 hours of
unpaid work and like you said they've
been banned from keeping cats for a
period of five years and on top of all
of that as well kurt zuma will have to
pay charges of nearly 9 000 pounds now
this all of course pertains to that
snapchat video that was uploaded which
showed kurt volley volleying the cat
across the kitchen he threw shoes at it
and then proceeded to slap its head
whilst his younger son was holding the
cat
and last week in court it was
established that in the video kurt zuma
was heard saying i swear i'll kill it i
swear i'll kill it now today the court
heard that
the there were 80 followers on the
snapchat account five of these people
viewed the video and it was taken down
within around five minutes but last week
they also established that it did seem
to be premeditated as well the judge
described this behavior as being
disgraceful and reprehensible she said
that the cat was looking to kurt zuma
and his brother joanne to fulfill
its needs but it suffered from fear and
anxiety as a result we know that the cat
has been is being re-homed by the rspca
and as a consequence of this we also
know that kurt zuma has lost a
sponsorship deal he's been fined 250 000
pounds by his club west ham
and uh in the last few moments west ham
have also released a statement in which
they say that they condem in the
strongest terms any form of animal abuse
or cruelty they speak about the fine
that kurt was
issued with and they say that every
single penny of this will go
to deserving charities dedicated to
animal welfare so kurt zuma
and his brother joanne
banned from keeping cats for five years
and given 12-month community orders